[Música]
aqui nessa estação onde arranha-céu
conversar com deus lá de cima aqui nessa
questão de teu patrão recrutou do show
de agonia aqui no barracão onde falta o
pão pro menino na barriga onde não te
irmão motivo razão pra se levantar todo
dia é é é
[Música]
é
é ela quem chegou até o chão com sua
gangue da geração quanto vale o guri
favelado diante do seu central é ele
quem joga o teu chão com sua gangue da
geração quanto vale o guri favelado
diante do seu cinturão aqui nessa
estação é questão de cor o homem que
sabe na vida
cito fone mulher o preto da pele vai te
amarrar mais ainda mal sabe o guri que
acordava cedo para trabalhar todo dia
que um tijolo taco e edificou essa terra
tão distraída é
[Música]
é
é ele o menino pintal preto da pele de
prata' para trabalhar como se o preço
desse preconceito fosse só vogais a
trocar e um menino pintal preto da pele
de prata para trabalhar como se um preço
desse preconceito fosse só por gastar
trocar na pateira parar na barreira
thundera tuviras a pateira paraná
parreira terá no lira lá poderá fazer a
declaração de renato lira tapanã lareira
ponderada é
[Música]
é
e um menino pintar o preto da pele de
prata para trabalhar como se o preço
desse preconceito você só vocais a
trocar é quem chega pelo chão com sua
sangue da geração quanto vale o guri
favelado diante do seu sempre há quem
não se sinta tentado a princesa e menino
pintada de cinza ou menina pintado de
cinza foi menino pintado de cinza foi
menino o menino o menino pintado de
cinza
[Música]
[Aplausos]
é a brigada